peggy 16.
hi everyone welcome to our second
nintendo direct mini partner showcase
today we'll continue delivering the
latest information about upcoming
nintendo switch games exclusively from
our development and publishing partners
we'll be releasing more videos in the
series this year
so please be on the lookout okay
let's get into the headlines
experience the music of kingdom hearts
like never before
embark on a musical journey in a
rhythm-based world
stages are themed after locations from
the kingdom hearts series
and the disney universe match the rhythm
with good timing to achieve high scores
and use special abilities to attack and
defeat enemies
a variety of modes are available
including memory dive where you play
stages from past memories
and boss battle where you square off
against fearsome vote by dodging their
powerful attacks
clearing stages unlocks a music player
in story cinematics so you can relive
memorable scenes from the kingdom hearts
series
[Music]
compete against other players for high
scores in online and local multiplayer
a free-for-all mode exclusive to the
nintendo switch version
also features local play for up to eight
players
[Music]
maybe mickey plus experience an all new
chapter in this game
[Music]
kingdom hearts melody of memory launches
on nintendo switch november 13th
pre-purchase begins later today
[Music]
drop the beat and mix it up infuser
hey everyone zoe from harmonix here and
i'm so excited to give you one of our
first looks at collaborative multiplayer
infuser
our revolutionary music mixing game
coming this fall to the nintendo switch
system
as an added bonus i'm excited to
announce three new songs that will be on
the fuser soundtrack
ghosts and stuff from dead mouse dance
monkey from tones and i and blinding
lights by the weekend
if that wasn't enough we're also
revealing one of our all new larger than
life stages at the same time
let's get right to it so i've rounded up
three friends and we're each going to
take a turn at the decks
i'm leading things off and you can see
that my friends are digging it from all
the fire emojis they're throwing up
now it's troy's turn and i'm showing her
some emoji love this mix is definitely
chef's kiss
all right we've all taken our turns and
it's time to see who's had the hottest
mix
i hope you enjoyed this quick look at
fuser multiplayer in action we'll see
you on stage this fall
[Music]
use your drumming skills to save the
world
two games from the taiko new testagen
series make their way onto the nintendo
switch system in one pack
[Music]
join don chen in two great rpg
adventures by traveling through time or
by saving the world from strange
incidents
[Music]
face off against enemies in rhythmic
battles by chaining combos with powerful
taiko
drums recruit monsters to become your
allies
check each monster's personality and
create a formidable party to take down
fearsome foes
and if you like to enjoy just playing
along to the music a rhythm mode is
available
more than 130 songs are included in this
collection
drum to your heart's content in taiko
new testagen rhythmic adventure pack
coming to nintendo switch winter 2020
[Music]
command the legendary tanks and dominate
the battlefield
[Music]
[Applause]
world of tanks blitz launches on
nintendo switch later today
[Music]
train fight and win to become a boxing
champion
rise through the ranks in this knockout
boxing game
intuitive controls meet hard-hitting
fighting techniques for seamless action
experience a true underdog journey
through story driven interactions and
fierce battles
plus you can hone your boxing skills in
classic rocky training montages
in free play mode fight as rocky balboa
adonis creed and an entire roster of
fighting legends from the rocky and
crete franchises
including apollo creed ivan and victor
drago
and clubber lang local multiplayer is
also available so you can go head to
head with friends in adrenaline field
matches
step into the boxing ring in big rumble
boxing creed champions
coming to nintendo switch spring 2021
three classic handheld rpgs make their
way onto nintendo switch
originally released on the game boy in
japan and the us
the first three titles in the saga
series the final fantasy legend
final fantasy legend 2 and final fantasy
legend 3 are coming to nintendo switch
in one collection
and to europe for the very first time
navigate through fantasy worlds as you
fight monsters
customize your characters explore towns
battle dungeons
and more a high speed mode and other
helpful features have been added while
retaining the appeal of the original
titles
to commemorate the 30th anniversary of
the series a special anniversary song is
included
collection of saga final fantasy legend
will launch on nintendo switch december
15th
pre-purchase begins later today
[Music]
get the party going in the latest just
dance game
[Music]
and when you're done
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and when you're done
[Music]
the ultimate puzzle match returns
two legendary puzzle games reunite in
kyoto tetris two
the latest entry includes all of the
modes from the original game
including the popular versus mode that
lets you play puyo puyo against tetris
the playful party mode with special
items and challenges and more
the all-new skill battle mode introduces
skills and strategies that can quickly
turn the tide of battle
journey deeper into the worlds of puyo
puyo and tetris in adventure mode
starring a vibrant cast in a brand new
story
an expanded online mode is available
where up to four players can compete
against each other in worldwide battles
and there's a lot more to reveal get
ready for a public challenge like no
other
kuya puyo tekkers 2 drops onto nintendo
switch december 8th
we hope you've enjoyed this presentation
so far for our final announcement
we'll be taking a look at some games and
downloadable content launching soon on
nintendo switch
[Music]
fight the frock in the minecraft
dungeons creeping winter dlc
brave all new missions and take down
relentless mobs on your journey to
defeat the wretched wraith at the center
of the storm
hunt down the source of corruption and
discover new weapons
armor and artifacts when this dlc makes
its arctic appearance
this september unite to fight a
dangerous threat and save humankind
in jump force deluxe edition choose from
a roster of more than 50 powerful manga
heroes
from dragon ball naruto one piece and
more
battle in various modes including online
modes and a local tag team mode
exclusive to this version character pass
one is included with the full game
which punches its way to nintendo switch
august 28th
defy the rules of football in captain
tsubasa
rise of new champions execute powerful
offensive and defensive moves
to gain the advantage during
action-packed matches customize your
characters
build your dream team and compete in
online and local play
take your shots and score in this arcade
football game coming august 28th
call upon magic and might to protect
your world in this co-op action rpg
a grand adventure awaits complete with
new battles and weapons
updated graphics and more team up online
with friends
far and near or with other players in a
party matchmaking system
to fight fearsome foes final fantasy
crystal chronicles remastered edition
arrives august
27th that concludes today's nintendo
direct mini partner showcase
thank you for watching please look
forward to more partner showcase
presentations this year
[Music]
you